[Musica]
che c'è
benvenuti soli tasto risulti il nuovo
gioco
iniziando sull eterno svitiamo
dei fiori ma non c'è scritto attenzione
questo gioco contiene dei jones sapete
che io fa improvvisamente tantissimo
comunque il nuovissimo gioco dovremmo
scappare dalla stalker cioè c'è una
ragazza innamorata di noi che ci sto
hera è però è cattiva quindi dobbiamo
scappare da questa ragazza cattiva
tagliandi prendete il corno mettetevi
comodi lasciate un mi piace intorno le
mostre di prum vi abbiamo e non vedo
l'ora che i nein
stanotte però bisogno di qualcuno che mi
accompagna il promo sarebbe con la festa
americana quando finisce la scuola caso
il ballo ballo di fine anno beh però già
qualcuno in mente chiediamo a lei di
venire con me
scritto suonando speriamo che non sia la
folk
un po di olio su questa
non dovremmo essere qua avere un no non
credo proprio ok ma da controllare
nessuno sa che c'è
ecco la top kart mamma mia che deviò
paura dove siamo finiti questa casa è
grandissima meli armato è pazza dobbiamo
scappare d'acqua ok
ora l'entrata sembra che vada ora troppo
si dobbiamo recuperare tre chiavi per
uscire da qui che
sapete che io adoro le cose paurose e
questa casa è bellissima ho paura
a proposito di cose paurosa avete già
preso il mio libro storie paura da
scolari misteri se non l'avete ancora
presa cliccando su binari tele
prendetelo subito non potete non averlo
qua sotto sia un entrata in questo
corridoio gigante ma il roa possa stare
qua posso abitare qui
non lo so io avrei un po paura
che i fantasmi a lungo forse è la risata
della stalker malefica allora ho trovato
una chiave presa a si fa piacere che
ritiene il principio è un giocatore che
ho trovato una chiave anche mi guarda su
quelle scatole
si trovata sia un altro giocatore per
chi ha fatto una brutta perché ha sempre
il fiore in mano
altri giocatore che sono finiti male
abbiamo ci manca ancora una chiave
qui e lì affianco al baule guarda
andiamo
presa se vuole si può aprire anche noi
abbiamo un po breve ma dovevamo avere
ok queste dovrebbe essere suo
seminterrato la cantina proprio suo
nascondiglio
perché c'è una lavatrice
potrebbe essere un indizio non credo no
no no
ok vapore chelsea ha spiattellato per
dire come hai fatto a morire ma attento
quando diventa rosso devi stare fermo e
si
[Musica]
parli così riuscito a passare gravati
dai puoi farcela arrivo eccomi non ho
più i fiori no si sono seccati che
quando sei passata sotto il vapore si
sono appassionata wow magari sono
sfracellata incredibile allora o prova
la leva per attivare l'ascensore eni
forse dobbiamo scendere qui
sono frutto perché va a braccio il lato
dentro
devo dire la parola sfracellato ho
sentito qualcuno
ok
sfida sfida vediamo chi riesce a
limitare o meglio il suono di quando
morrison
[Musica]
prova io
o
meglio tu hai vinto lesa e non avrete
[Musica]
lo abbiamo trovato una leva c'è scritto
che è lasciato aggiustando fixing sì mi
raccomando ragazzi studiano l'inglese
perché se studiate l'inglese capirete
tutti come giochiamo
non so blocco di videogiochi capirete
che credo che abbia funzionato si guarda
qui ci sono le leve che devo aspettare
che risalga
via a marzo
l'ascensore che cosa è successo alle
luci si sono fatte le luci o no
non la vedo
marco legami a e brutti e notò mamma mia
dobbiamo scappare no no no no no no no
no aiuto aiuto 6 seguendo tre ma quando
si ha un labirinto questa bellissima
sembra non lo so ma appena uscita male
fino per poco mi ha preso avevano
trovato l'uscita meno male è lenta
inquietante ma noi piacciono le stesse
camere fa paura tempiese posto per
pregiati di coraggio la lazio non
riusciamo ad uscire se ce l'ha fatta
vitale penso salsano
nostra destra
bravo
ce l'hai fatta per un pelo vengo una
fetta tutto voglio fare meglio in vita o
poi metterlo in un paio di mangiarlo
aiuto se è mancato poco
wow sembra ci siano delle trappole
non dobbiamo toccarle
quando mi raccomando non attiva no no
io sono riuscito a passare sa
che stanza strano
sono i denti gli occhi tratterà allora
qui c è gigantesca cosa c'è un buco nel
pavimento fare qua sotto dobbiamo andare
a ok se vuote
ok siamo passati al livello successivo
il senso carraio
che figo
dobbiamo prendere cinque chiavi inglesi
ok 55 mentre abbiamo sì ma è un'altra
ecco la testa ok ma è questa stage è
stato abbastanza semplice
e qui e quindi
attento non farti prendere non ho però
delle scintille verdi e adolescenti
come stop per
[Musica]
la senti li sta risvegliando qualcosa o
molto paura fra l'altro top si appena
diventa verde bio dop come fatto no si è
preso non lo so
vedi sono proprio qui sono tutte le sue
vittime dice
i vostri diventata anche duravit ios
come hai fatto è perché ho toccato uno
di quelli là quindi devo stare attento a
non toccare questi giocatori stai
accennato di non toccare niente è come
tutti siamo certo è molto strana la casa
di questa ragazza si tra l'altro
nasconde delle scorie radioattive
costoso attento a non farsi friggere
[Musica]
qualcuno vuole spiegarci ha vinto
io
ma mi ha
detto aspettiamo unità che si sfracelli
cosa fatta o no ma quantità no
dai dai l'ultimo quello
che questa luce
le sue vittime sono ancora vive ops in
che senso
ha
parlare dobbiamo anche difenderci dagli
occhi aspetti si è scritto qua zombie sì
io scappo ciao
mi sta inseguendo
zombie non ti apprezzo sì ma adesso sono
diventato chironi zombie aiuto
riesco a capirlo
o mama ti ngo scavo è lo lascio perdere
questo zombie mi sa che ci insegue
si conviene scappare nome sono sentiti
mi sto scappando tutti mi stanno
seguendo
[Musica]
tu
sai che ti hanno preso
bene a sarah mi hanno presa di zombie ma
mia spiaccicato una sorta di rullo
però almeno nota eccoci qui
non farti spiaccicare bisogna
schiacciati no no
mi stanno continuando ad inseguire
questi ultimi anni e mezzo ma che cos'è
una fabbrica qualcosa è
cominciata presto chi da questa parte
è
un due tre stella guaio dorud tre stella
stop attento
[Musica]
che il ragazzo malefica
anche un bebè velocissima
basta guardarla perché si gira la vedevi
si muove prima che si te
ce l'ho fatta e firmata dai
per un pelo
bene come facciamo a prendermi cieli
quasi ti mancava così poco prezzi
vicinissima di
macro
e micro e mini
è la tigre di metà maggio sembra quello
dimosterà in company ve lo ricordate rm
anche aveva preso
catturato volevo dire
motivazione per non essere presa
aspettami ora ci aspetta un par tour con
bega velocità dai puoi farcela vitale è
fatto scappare dalla gomma cona è stata
di saltare dai dopo c'è una parte super
divertente e non vedo l'ora non vedo
cosa non si fa
motivo il pavimento è nata wow eccomi
ecco vitale presto abbiamo prendi la
chiave le imprese no non avevo neanche
servizi presta grazie qui credo ce ne
sia un'altra qui dietro guarda l'hai
presa la seconda a non è lui
no quindi alla terza testa e si genera
un altra dietro vicino gli altri bidoni
ok marche abbiamo tra chiave di tutto
che dobbiamo andare a possiamo aprire
questa porta vai
[Musica]
sembra la casa degli specchi questa wow
io adoro la casa de vita perché aiuto
c'è lei no
credo che uno zombie come cammina e
proni ma io adesso più mi perderò lo fa
ne sono sicuro che l'abito giusto puro
lei è qui dietro di noi unità sappi che
distrusse guendo indietro di nove
milioni
per favore trova mia voglio storia fa
paura è trovato presso la giusta sì ma
ci sono dei coltelli che vogliono
aspettarsi wow
[Musica]
contro finale ma devo prendere questa
bazooka facoltà giù così da oggi
vogliono i robot o no e allora come la
devo affrontare ma è un
carro armato aiuto qualcuno mi dica come
devono affrontare la stalker malefica
vedi se c'è qualcosa qui che vuoi
prendere
invece un unicorno
certo l'unicorno con sosterrà armato e
forse devo solo scappare non sta a noi
guardatevi premere uno è il fatto che
adesso
allora prova a colpirla a
capita solo una volta finora e in che
quantità davvero alta vabbè ma devo
scappare come posso solo finirla forse
devo salire qua sopra miglio
diceva mia madre
ma non so sparando non sta funzionando a
vita per andare più lontana
no
o cosa è successo
[Musica]
dai cinesi riproviamoci di nuovo però
forse stavolta tutto bene ecco
voglio prendere quello dai ben
più in alto vai colpisce più in altri
sorpresa mai allora la colpirò solo
d'acqua brava più in alto va
sempre presa
pecca di questo sport che nella norma ce
n'è voluto non con 15 10 clienti
bloccata lì forse qualche bug perfetto
così
wow
non mi sono niente dovuta muovere
d'azione al mio compagno non è così lei
sta sparando al muro
no però vede che li fa comunque deviare
per scrivere dai l'ultimo l'ultimo
successo
penso che puoi togliere il bazooka
certo punto
quando sei riuscito a scappare
siamo usciti dalla testa dello stalker
fino ai pet mi raccomando non chiediamo
mai più agli stalker di andare al ballo
di fine anno
vi piace la finass 4 kasami diverse qui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite